if you want to engage in respectful
political discussion with other viewers
of the show and other listeners you can
do that on the david pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT a couple of very interesting
posts that I noticed this morning one is
that apparently Dinesh D'Souza and Jesse
Lee Peterson were engaged in what is
ostensibly loosely being called an
interview I've been interviewed by Jesse
Lee Peterson a couple times he is this
completely out there right winger who
somehow has gotten picked up on Newsmax
television unless he's already been
kicked off of that I don't really know
he interviewed convicted felon Dinesh
D'Souza who of course I don't even know
if we can say that because really
pardoning him and I don't know if you
can still say it's a he's a formerly
former convict I guess you would say and
I'm not even gonna present anything else
to you other than to tell you this was a
contest for the dumbest assertions about
politics that I've maybe ever heard and
I don't know who won Dinesh or Jesse Lee
take a listen do you see Richard Spencer
as a bad guy I see him as a misguided
guy who's on the left in other words
when I say on the left here's what I
mean
number one he believes in identity
politics identity politics as this
identity politics is the belief that the
most important thing about you is what
ethnic group or race you belong to now
see I don't believe that but he believes
that I don't know I think he only
believes that because they've been so
white guys especially and especially
white straight man they're so under tied
and they've been prevented from speaking
up for the last 16 years or so aerobatic
use I just made me a mad about the way
they have been treated right but I mean
we're boiling stating they're coming out
like that agreed but remember like I
would say that the angry nationalism of
say Malcolm X came in response to what
he saw as white nationalism right and
Malcolm X goes if we don't fight back as
a group and so now Richard is the next
turn of the screw and so he represents a
kind of bitter white nationalism
responding to what he sees as the
minority national yeah he goes well his
bet we have black power we have Latino
power we have this power we have that
power
we have white power right that's
basically argument you know and but I
don't think Trump's on that on that no
no no Trump is a you know we're
Americans first I don't know
look let me start a different way given
that you have to save the things Dinesh
D'Souza said to be kept on that show and
to be considered a good guest I see it
as a badge of honor that Jesse Lee
Peterson threw me off of his show do you
even want to go into that point-by-point
debunking the claim by these guys I
would say the dumbest thing Dinesh
D'Souza said is probably that Richard
Spencer is on the left and the dumbest
thing Jesse Lee Petersen said is
probably that the big discrimination
that's currently taking place is against
straight white men in American society
but of those two claims it's hard to say
what's very hard to rank one over the
other yeah
also from the david pakman show
subreddit which i spotted this morning
will trump be let off like Reagan in
iran-contra this is a question from
quite frankly someone who regularly
trolls but they said I have a feeling
that Russia gate will end up like
iran-contra instead of like Watergate I
don't think the topic Trump's cabal will
be held accountable agree or disagree
Reagan still went down as objectively
the most corrupt and criminal
administration in the US history with a
hundred and thirty eight administration
officials investigated and itíd and/or
convicted of crimes I actually agree and
I think unless we see a complete
reversal in who controls the House and
Senate in what is it like ten weeks
in in the common term election you're
not going to see Trump held accountable
it's very possible that many members of
his administration or his cabal will be
held accountable but I actually think
that there's a lot to what this person
is saying you had asked me last week
maybe I would have said that this is
more in line with iran-contra and Reagan
yeah you asked me today after the events
of this week I don't know it's shaping
up like Watergate I think it is actually
taken towards Watergate yeah I mean I
hope it is and most importantly I hope
that justice is served in a fair and
non-political way because that's really
what we care about I happen to think
that if that happened it would be the
complete destruction of Donald Trump's
presidency and that would be the correct
way that justice would be served but if
the evidence does
point that way then tell us Robert molar
assuming that he can do the
investigation fully and fairly come out
and say this is as far as it goes and I
don't think there was anything else I'm
ready for him to say that and I'm ready
for him to say Trump really should be
impeached and then charged with crimes
we will see